[Music]
[Music]
if you're watching this on your phone
it's partly thanks to Captain Kirk in
Star Trek first broadcast in 1966 he
used a pocket-sized device to
communicate with his crew Martin Cooper
the man who invented the mobile phone
says the show was the inspiration for
his idea which launched seven years
later Amazon founder Jeff Bezos based
Alexa the voice-activated speaker on
Star Trek's
talking computer translated engaged
welcome aboard
sci-fi fan Elon Musk is building rockets
carry people to pass submarines
helicopters rockets and touchscreens all
appeared in science fiction before
becoming science fact
sci-fi inspires real world technology it
also provides a way to explore the moral
dilemmas that advanced technologies
could pose
[Music]
Paul McCauley is a scientist turn
science fiction writer all science
fiction is basically about is present so
it's about a heightened version of the
present is about anticipating where
technology is going to go and it's about
our fears of where technology is going
to go or what uses or misuses we might
make of that technology few films better
encapsulate this than Ridley Scott's
1982 cult classic Blade Runner
the film is set in a dystopian future
where synthetic human workers are
bioengineered by a corporate power
in London fans were arriving for a Blade
Runner screaming with a difference
[Music]
we are in world terminus checkpoint for
point C we're in Los Angeles
in 2019 secret cinema is a multi-layered
physical experience we build these
physical sets creating a world inspired
by affluence so instead of just watching
a film you literally buy a ticket you
become a character and you become part
of an interactive theatrical experience
I think the science fiction genre allows
us to dream about another world we've
taken inspiration from Blade Runner and
built an entire world around it the film
explores the ethical implications of
creating highly intelligent robots that
have thoughts feelings and emotions I
was just back from a convention about AI
artificial intelligence in Cambridge and
a lot of the AI people you think about
what would happen if really I came on
very powerfully what they would do to us
and that's one of the things that
science fiction has been exploring for
quite a long time there Steven
Spielberg's latest movie ready player
one explores another emerging technology
virtual reality
the film imagines a future where
overpopulation pollution and climate
change have forced most people to live
in sprawling slum like cities young
people escape the desolation by living
much of their lives in virtual reality
are you ready
[Music]
although there is a wide gap between the
virtual worlds shown in the film and the
capabilities of current VR technology
the idea that young people can get
hooked on virtual fantasies is a
long-standing concern to be compelling
science fiction has to be convincing
so writers and film directors enlists
the help of designers and engineers Syd
Mead designed the look of some of
Hollywood's most seminal sci-fi films
including Blade Runner Star Trek the
motion picture and aliens in the real
world he's designed cars for Ford and
electronics for Phillips because I'm a
trained designer I can imagine how
things might be made people always say
that my stuff looks real even though
it's futuristic the pods for aliens that
I designed were real mechanical
articulations so when they opened it
looked absolutely real for people to be
in for long-duration space travel I was
hired to design the vehicles for
policemen on Decker's vehicle was in my
mind a decommissioned luxury aerial
limousine it's overlaying the familiar
with the weird and that's a surefire
formula for interesting things to look
at science fiction introduces people to
real-world science and technology
some fans develop a lifelong passion the
tech industry is led by sci-fi nerds who
are creating the things they read about
or saw on screen we all stand to benefit
from their creations provided that is
they can avoid the ethical pitfalls
depicted in science fiction
you
you